hey guys welcome to the watered podcast
I'm James Marshall and today I've got an
episode for you around mental health and
I know after releasing the last episode
with Shane Christie um I guess that just
emphasized how important it is to keep
talking about this topic and had so many
messages from people around um wanting
to hear more so here I've got a guest
Who Um can hopefully give you some tools
around some of the things that he's
learned through his journey and his
professional rugby career so really
looking forward to you listening to this
there's lots of good stuff in here for
whether it's you or um potentially
friends or anyone going through
something so um hope you enjoy this
episode uh what a l well something I've
always wanted to do with this platform
is to use it to be able to help people
and I'm still getting messages from
retired athletes about that Tim baitman
episode that I released so really Keen
to do more episodes like that where we
can get someone who has super good
knowledge on some area where they can
help others and for today episode I have
the perfect guest for the topic of
mental health and he's got plenty of
tools where he can help and handle um
different challenges of Pro Sport throws
at you but not just Pro Sport but life
in general he is of course a massive lad
he's been on water lad already and
shared his incredible story he is the
hard man of New Zealand Rugby in this
country it is of course the great Hugh
Ron welcome
mate Jimmy um Che inro it's always funny
to hear you go I'd forgot what I'd
written there so I was just reading that
off the top some of it was made up but
it was um good to get you on and um
obviously had you on before and it's
quite cool seeing your journey where
it's at now I think what two two and a
bit years later and remember you
speaking about where you wanted to get
to and had a really good year on the
field last year for the Highlanders and
really establish yourself as you know
one of the best loose forwards in the
country geers yeah it's it's uh yeah
good to be here and uh um yeah obviously
we've talked over the years and then a
couple years ago went on the podcast and
um yeah time goes quick and um losing my
ha Qui quicker
sorry but I do want to get into like
what you're pretty King to come on and
speak about is the mental health side of
not just sport but life in general and
something you're very passionate about
and um speaking to you about it
previously I feel like what you talk
about um
can add so much value to not just rugby
players around the country or the world
but people in just general Society who
um are going through some
issues yeah um no tot totally agree I
think it's just um I remember um yeah
just hearing people say you know if you
had have gone through experience that
might help someone who hasn't gone
through it yet or might go through it um
you know you should uh share it and I
guess um when we those couple of yars um
as you mentioned I might have gone
through a couple of experiences that
might help help people so if I can share
and give some advice and what could have
helped me or or helped me then um then
yeah why not say it and um yeah with
with that though like I think if anyone
is seriously going through something
right now um seek medical professional
help like uh I'm not a professional or
anything like that and I think that's
your first call to to go to a
professional um doctor and or psych and
and yeah get get onto that really quick
um but yeah happy to share what I've
gone through and and have a Yar so let's
start it like where did mental health
sort of all start for you and like your
journey good question I think um it
definitely has sort of been around a
little bit and and the older I've got um
things that have happened in the past
have have sort of been brought to light
and I'll be like oh yeah that's probably
you know something I had then and
anxiety Then but at the time I wouldn't
have even recognized it yeah oh but I I
remember like um yeah at at high school
like um like trying to play rugby and
then getting like injuries at school and
then sort of would would freak out about
um being able to get back on the Rugby
field or be super anxious about um about
performing well or something like that
when I was sort of you know under St
sort of side of things um and then
potentially like didn't perform well and
then got dropped from um Hawks under 14s
at that time and then sort of freaked
out about my Rugby career being finished
and all that sort of stuff so I mean
like all the way back back to then you
know um I can remember little butts and
um as you get older you sort of
recognize oh that's why I reacted then
or this is why I reacted then and so I
think that's been um probably the the
most exciting part of um this this whole
journey is actually recognizing the
patterns within my history or myself um
and and then yeah just just recognizing
that and then having better systems in
place um for future events really um and
it's not always been easy and I haven't
even for a long time there knowing how
to handle things or anything but where
I'm at right now I feel like I've um
gone through a few things in things are
starting to work um it doesn't mean you
don't have stresses or pressure or or
mental health disruptions as I like to
call it um but you just get better at
recognizing it and having a system to
come out the other side and manage it
effectively really I look forward to
hearing some of those tools but I guess
for people who haven't heard your first
story I guess the pretty important parts
of your journey especially on the field
were the fact that you assigned very
young but bu the Hurricanes you had a
shoulder that wasn't working for about
three years and didn't get to play so
you had that um I guess expectation of
being a school boy star signed at a
young age and not being able to prove
your worth into a professional
environment so that was I guess one key
moment for you right yeah definitely and
then um from the back back side of that
they will talk about is um yeah um
having no contracts extended or anything
like that at 2021 yeah so you're left to
the complete
Wilderness of rugby if if that's what
you wanted to continue but you're right
like I at um sort of 17 um ended up um
having basically a paralyzed arm um yeah
sort of woke up one day played a couple
games and and something was up with my
shoulder and my neck and then woke up
one day was searing pain down my um
right shoulder and couldn't lift my arm
and if anyone's had like a stinger or
some nerve pain it's like a hot knife
just through the absolute body so that
chronic pain was just in my shoulder for
a good few weeks and and and then when
that pain left um couldn't lift up my
arm above horizontal because my status
interior all the whole Underside and
back side of my arm uh had had stopped
working and the nerve to that that
controlled that muscle sto working um
and with that was um a big challenge
because it wasn't like a stock standard
injury like you'll return in 6 months or
9 months and you do XYZ and you'll come
back yeah so at that time that was a big
um big smack in the face because I
remember being at school then U wanting
to have a promising career and at at
that time I um was fortunate enough to
be in the hurricane schools and and and
amongst the under 18 stuff and all of
that so um as a school boy that's like
the Pinnacle you think at that time
because that's like your life and
everything and then for that to be sort
of like ripped away of injury um and
then not knowing when I would play um
some people would say oh you'll be back
in a month or you'll be back in six
weeks or eight weeks and then four weeks
went past six weeks went past nothing
had changed you know two months had gone
past nothing had changed and no timeline
no timeline which is extremely hard and
at that time I was like um
you put all your hope into reaching that
um destination of like yep it'll be
right in a month or yep it'll be right
in six weeks and then when you got there
and it wasn't right there was just a
massive um blow to the to the psyche um
and it reminds me of like Victor Franco
um he's he wrote a book U man search for
meaning and about he's a um psychiatrist
and um con concentration camps and he
said the people that
uh uh didn't last were the people that
were holding on for an end dat yeah and
so they would hold on for the end dat
and then they wouldn't be freed and they
would suffer massive um consequences
from that whereas if you sort of just
recognize what the situation was and be
like okay what can I do to be in the
best shape um that would have saved me a
lot of pain cuz I I remember um at that
time um I was doing and stuff fine but I
would be like looking in the mirror
trying to work my arm like um couldn't
lift up and answer a phone call and my
bicep would just be burning um and I'd
be just so stressed at night like
anxiety through the roof about it
getting right or what what I could do
like I felt like I needed to like chop
off my arm or something like that like
reading up on surgeries and one surgery
was they had to um wire your scapula
down to your rib cage so you could muff
your arm and I was like looking at all
this stuff and then thank God I didn't
do any of that stuff um but that's the
holes that you can get into and I
remember for for a long time there I
would um I would just be so anxious
about trying to get it right and like
praying to God to get it right and I
would fall asleep at like 2:00 a.m. like
um on like the couch in my room or like
on the side of my bed or not even be in
bed properly I just fall asleep from
exhaustion wake up fully wide at like
6:30 7: a.m. ready for school do the
school day be distracted by that and
then come back and see you know my arm
would wouldn't be right and then I'd be
same again up all night wanting to W
that to existence and it will get right
you know dream about it coming right and
pray to God and stuff like that then it
wouldn't be right and then I fall asleep
again wake up and be so stimulated again
so that whole time on my last year of
school like I just was so wide and then
that would cause other problems from
like your back going or other injuries
and niggles um just because your whole
body was stuck in such a sythetic wide
State and then throw on top of that um
you know being contracted uh out of out
of school like from my perspective it
was opportunity to do everything a kid
had dreamed about playing professional
rugby uh an opportunity to be amongst
sort of the best one of the best teams
in New Zealand and stuff like that so
why not take it and I just think I
probably didn't handle that whole time
as effectively as I could have um
initially it was from A hurricane's
perspective it was like a no-brainer
like I was um out for two years at
minimum so they could sign a player but
it wouldn't even affect the salary cap
or whatever and there's a big thing in
New Zealand around um retaining youth
talent and stuff like that in their
regions and so you could sign a guy that
was in the team but then not have it
impact your salary cap or anything like
that so um why wouldn't you do it and so
from their perspective was probably um
easy because it wouldn't even affect the
team but from my perspective I was like
yeah I'm ready to go I wanted to go and
then that internal conflict of like
pushing myself to be ready but then my
body's not even working and it's wasn't
even working a little bit like my arm
was not working at all and coming from
like a first 15 that wasn't a massive 15
school we hadn't even run like proper
line outs and stuff and you got like you
know some of the best line out fors like
Victor V best line out for in the
country and I'm trying to like do
exactly what he is and stuff like that
comparing yourself to yeah comparing
yourself to those guys and fully grown
men like bread Shields and stuff um and
and just a youthful confidence um that
comes from basically having no
limitations you think you can take on
the world which is a good driver cuz it
gets you in the arena and stuff like
that but not really realizing the
reality that one my arm couldn't work
and one there's a quite a lot of
development and things that had to go in
place so even throughout that time um
which probably extended my time off the
field because um I was in such a stress
State internally of trying to catch up
and everything off in terms of rugby and
then trying to catch up everything in my
arm and stuff and I was in the gym doing
like a million exercises um you know um
all these band exercises and all that
sort of stuff like just I probably spent
all my time in the gym just thinking
that that would get it right and then
from there then you develop into like o
you develop stuff like OCD Tendencies
and perfectionism Tendencies and things
like that which is fine but then when
it's uncontrolled and it can be a real
detriment and and then those things
start to derail you right and so so what
did that look like for you well for
example um 502
yeah well that that was I never actually
chewed my food 50 times put it out there
but that's an example of of of it for
sure like I I gained control of my
situation because um physios and stuff
which basically ruled my life at that
time because I wanted to get my body
back able they said you do 25 bloody um
external rotation exercises it will get
better I do 25 and then I'll do another
25 and then you know you just start
getting into a habit of like doing
things trying and do things perfectly
and trying to do things all perfect and
for me like that's where I that's the
only place I saw progression in my life
was basically doing things like really
regimentally like that um and then also
like I remember being in in a time when
I was trying to like I just thought
thought I just didn't have any luck so I
was like oh yeah if I do like make my p
a certain way do these exercises train
like I'll get better luck and I'll get
you know more luck and then from that
things will flow and my arm will be
better and things will be better and so
I started doing you know everything to
just such a Perfection
perfectionistic detailed way uh and just
develop bad habits um that were
detrimental because um there's no
guarantee that you do 25 reps of your
arm exercise and it was going to get
right you know what I mean um and so
when you come onto the Rugby field as
well like at that time I
remember um I because I hadn't stepped
on a rugby field for a couple years so I
knowing like all the plays and
everything that we had um on pieces of
paper but as a you know immediately as a
rugby player we already know that things
never go to plan or they change and I
would look at the way the loose Fords
were where there was um these the the
eights in the middle and the um seven
and sixes on the edge and then um these
are certain players that would happen
and and all on piece of paper it would
be a certain way and so I'd have that in
my mind go out there and you w f like
and Victor and stuff like that and I
just pull things like random things out
and I was like my head was exploding
because my whole life was such a rented
State and then I was there and I just
was like what the heck it was such a
wakeup call you know what I mean yeah
and so um is like those mental things
that I um that that that looked like and
I suffered with as well um and and again
um through that whole process it's just
a process of learning and so just learn
to recognize that and then see what um
what's the right way to do things or or
the way things flow or whatever but it's
the process that I sort of had to go
through I guess and and went through um
and for a lot of time there caused a lot
of mental pain because um things weren't
done the the way it was um sort of in my
head or anything like that and through
my R career at that time like I wanted
to get to you know playing and playing
well and being in the top of your game
or anything like that and then basically
had developed such a training regiment
and then it wasn't translated into the
field and then that was adding to like
more an anxiety Then you start doubting
yourself am I even going to be good am I
even good rugby player or anything like
that um and I had and then by the end of
my contracts there I decided to string a
good few games together um and actually
got on top of all that sort of stuff and
was doing a good couple of things on the
field but you know I was still like
miles away I was like 20 years old still
miles away where I needed to be and um
and and and that was my time with injury
and and and the first taste Taste of
professional rugby you know what I mean
and then then that all Ed in 2017 and so
yeah so if if you were going back in
time what would you do differently to
handle that injury at such a young age
yeah well something that's really helped
me um we can dive into more detail of
that but and long story short is like um
there's the fantasy and the fantasy is
what we want right the fantasy is the
perfect picture Okay I want to be this
type of player I want to um things to be
this s of way and
for uh my reality uh was just just not
not great and where I wanted to be
because I was either injured not where I
wanted to be in rugby and I was
suffering then um so I was suffering
because my reality was not what I wanted
and then I was suffering because the
fantasy was um I was stuck in the
fantasy and I was trying to make the
fantasy reality and I wasn't aware of
actually the proper process of doing
that cuz you know thought oh yeah I want
to be ex type of rugby player I want to
be driven I need to think like that and
push like that and constantly work at
things and do that but that was just
muddling me up so if I went um back in
time I would be like okay where am I
right now in reality okay your arms not
working you're this type of R player
that's just entering into professional
space your body's here your mind's here
when you step onto a rby field you might
have anxiety or stress or pressure and
this might happen so that's reality of
where you are
the fantasy is I want to be this type of
exciting player I want to do this on the
field I want to be here okay how do I
get there see where you are in reality
see see where you want to go and then
bridge that Gap by putting steps in
place and then I say that's like that's
putting the bricks down so you're
putting the brick down so that might be
um doing your gym and then that's one
brick and then that might be like see we
are okay fantasy I want to be this type
of player but there's uh things I need
to learn okay learn the line out first
and do that and then you start putting
the bricks down and then through that
and through actioning those steps the
fantasy becomes reality whereas if you
get stuck in just solely the fantasy of
I want to be there here now I want to be
this type of rugby player I want to my
body to work but you you see that it's
not working you suffer and for a long
time I was suffering and I was slow
through that process of actioning things
um but and I was suffering the whole
time whereas if I went back I would be
like okay yes I want to be here how do I
get there XY Z where am I right now and
actually just accept where I am right
now whereas I was just not accepting of
it at all you know like sitting in my
room praying to the god gods and like
willing my arm to get right and just
just trying to like force everything to
be the fantasy whereas I should have
looked at it and be like okay this is we
are right now what you can do as Xyz to
get you in the best possible shape for
that fantasy to come true and then
that's all you could do you know that's
the only thing you had control of at
that time whereas um yeah if you just
sit there like I I was then you can
ruminate and get into a deep cycle of
like trying to get things thing and then
you don't see evidence of getting there
and then that date comes that it should
have been there and you're not so then
that adds more stress and pressure
whereas back to what Victor Frankle did
he would just okay what do I need to do
I need to survive this next five minutes
I need to survive the next 10 minutes I
need to just um keep my mind centered
where my feet are right now you know
what I mean whereas focus on a future
date and you put all of your attention
to that um you just don't take the
actionable steps that actually move you
towards the fantasy that you want M that
is powerful stuff and good to get a
couple of Victor fr anle quotes in early
he's a true legend and I did enjoy that
book also but you also mentioned when um
you were a 20 you came out of that rugby
rugby bubble so like this is obviously a
situation that a lot of players or
everyone will get there at some point
usually at the end of their career but
you've hit that bubble really early um
dreamed of being a professional rby
player you've had a taste of it for
three years but never really got much of
a and then you're out of it and what
what was that feeling like and how did
you manage that oh mate like that time
of my life was um was was crazy cuz yeah
it was it was something that you'd never
want to happen it was almost like one of
your worst things that happen happens
and so it's like holy [__] and the way I
actually dealt with both in the end
which I got got there in the end with my
shoulder
injury um to get back playing rugby
first and then the not having contracts
was I I basically retired in my mind
twice did yeah like literally yeah
that's the way I dealt with it um and I
didn't retire in the in fact I gave up
like I never gave up and people might
have said oh because I went to UNI and
can and get on that but oh you went
there for uni no I went there for rugby
but people say uh you know like like for
me it was it was full retire in my mind
okay yeah I retire and with that took
basically the pressure of the fantasy or
the thing that you want off you and then
it allowed you to focus on where I was
right now in the reality okay and what
do I need to do and I remember with my
arm like I sat there and I was trying to
get it back perfect um functional and
everything like that and it just would
never be the same and even now it's not
the same as it was but I'm okay with it
and it's actually incredibly functional
and it's fine and I don't have any
issues with it yeah except it cramps up
sometimes but um I had to be like okay
at that time if I never play rugby again
or professional or whatever like that I
just have to accept it and like that's
so scary right yeah and like that's so
hard for someone to do because it feels
like you're giving up but by absolutely
dropping that facade of of trying to be
someone or trying to be a certain type
away or anything like that it allowed me
to see where I was and just go okay it
might not be perfect I might not ever be
back playing rugby I might not be a
professional but I'm going to do what I
can with what I can right now and with
that allowed me to just be like humans
aren't perfect I'm not perfect okay I'll
jump on Rugby field and see and I had a
couple of instances where my arm stuffed
out about three or four coming back that
year coming back when my arm would blow
out wouldn't work AC joint gone uh
wouldn't work and then eventually got
through the chiter or got through the
bloody Jungle of all the unknowing and
ended up back playing rugby and then got
through that whereas if I didn't retire
my mind and and take that fantasy away I
probably would have still been searching
for that perfect arm and like getting my
arm back to normal yeah but like it it
wasn't going to be normal cuz
Something's Happened to it extremely
Happ to and the same thing with my
career right um so I basically got
retired without having any professional
rugby contracts and so I had to be like
okay if I never play rugby
again you know face that ultimate face
that fear and then you just fully have
to accept it and then okay where am I
right now and what do I want to do I
want to be best R rugby player in the
world okay what do I need to do need to
do this and type turns of rugby this and
that and then by doing that I got better
at rugby and then got a contract again
yeah but if I was trying to like do the
perfect picture and be a professional
rby player make it and all that sort of
stuff I would have just stumbled along a
lot so the way I dealt with those two
times was actually literally Rock Bottom
uh it felt like at the time retire from
rugby basically in your mind to cut the
fantasy away and cut the facade away and
see where I am right now and then move
forward from there and yeah that's how I
dealt with that that's that's that's
powerful way to do it and is that why
you went down to Christ Church un
Canterbury uni was it
to give yourself something else Park
that pressure of becoming that player
take away that fantasy like you
mentioned and then um still in the back
of your mind having hopes that you're
going to come right and still play rugby
but just giving yourself that next
pathway yeah correct well there's a bit
of both to that so I sat down um with
with myself and and and mom as a great
support at that time um and said you
know what do I want to do okay so you
scrap everything right back to where you
are right now fully acceptant of the
situation that I'm in uh it was where I
am didn't have a degree didn't have any
Ry contracts what do I want to do I want
to okay I think I like accounting or
money um business money what's the nuts
and bolts of business okay accounting
and finance okay I can study that where
can I study that I can study that at
these universities canbury was one of
them okay so that was that side the
rugby side okay what do I want to do got
nothing whatever want to be XYZ want to
play uh rugby and get better where's the
best place probably Club rugby and
Canterbury is probably good probably
professional um in terms of professional
though the best place in New Zealand I
think it's understandable like world and
stuff like that okay actually canb is
the best place for me to be a rugby
player of where I am right now yeah and
I knew the hurdles of there were no
contracts there for like two three years
in terms of just the NPC team um there's
a massive backlog but again just keep
going back to what you can control right
now forget the facade forget the fantasy
um that internal driver is always going
to be there but how do you make that
reality it's by being where you are
right now and putting that bridge Brick
by Brick down to get to where you want
to go and that's why I went down there
for um for the rugby but then also the
outside of rugby because I can't just
live in a fantasy of of dreaming about
being a rugby player when you're bloody
playing D two club or something like
that so you got to you know you got to
accept that sh I got to be doing
something else too and rugby doesn't
last forever as we all know and so you
want to be doing something else and
that's yeah that's that's why I did the
outside of rugby and the in rugby and
canb was the best place for it and
although it was so hard to navigate
through and so many
challenges and
actually having the purpose and being
there allowed me to just face all those
challenges um yeah with uh yeah great
resolve really and um it ended up being
um the best place for me to be and I
think has helped my Rugby so much
because gets you out of the rugby bubble
you know you get real life experience
you're you're working there you're
trying to study plus play rugby as well
as you can um you're having to compete
with everyone the academy systems
stacked up there there's so much talent
and plus it's um they got a great as you
know you're you're in there you know
whether you're playing club or NPC or
whatever it's all kind of it's a small
town right everyone knows all the rugby
players and stuff so it's quite easy to
uh get involved and get opportunity so
that's why I made the decision to go
down there and it wasn't an easy
decision in terms of my whole life it
was an easy decision in terms of what I
wanted to do but at that time um my dad
had just passed away and so I was
leaving um Mom uh who I was living
closer to being around HS Bay Wellington
she's in HS Bay uh to Canterbury and
literally just after my almost a couple
months after my dad had passed away so
wasn't easy in terms of that and mom
gave me uh H bu to you know Chase my
dreams and stuff like that and and yeah
that's where I went down there it's so
cool from your mom like to give you that
blessing to Chase the Dream that she
obviously knew that you wanted to do and
um you did obviously you've spoken about
why that was your reason to go down
there but um I'm also Keen to hear a
little bit more about your dad cuz I
know you're ke to talk about that and
it's something that not many people are
open to talking about CU it's such a
hard conversation and um your dad
obviously farmer Champion man um how did
it happen or what do you remember about
it yeah um so yeah so those um you that
don't know my father unfortunately
passed away to suicide and
um that was
that's just just crazy because
um I sort of knew a bit about mental
health and and things like that we all
think we do um but we never think that
it would ever affect you MH or your
family just I think like um cancer like
I'd never thought you know had never
affected my family or anything like that
mental health had never affected my
family in the in the you know obvious or
anything and then for my dad to pass
away to Suicide was just like what the
heck and it's just completely completely
flipped my life upside down and will
never be the same forward or anything
like that
um
and in that time
like I'd never um seen my dad suffer in
terms of the noticeable anxiety
depression everything too like I'd never
seen them um battle or anything or be
stuck in his room or anything like that
he was always like such a strong pillar
of um of not just our family but
Community um you know people look up to
him I looked up to him so strong and
resilient and Fierce and so I was like
it's just so confusing like how can a
man who was that resilient then be
deemed not resilient by um falling into
the traps of um suicide
and I was just so confused at the time
and still have a lot of unanswered
questions but we never get answers to
those questions and and the thing is is
is with all of
that
um is you have to be extremely proactive
in your own mental health and you have
to be proactive in the factors not
letting yourself fall into a mental
and that's where unfortunately my dad
went wrong is he his mind fell into a
deep hole which then when you're in that
hole you don't know what's up or down
it's like flying a plane and a complete
white out you don't know what's up down
left or right and you could be flying
into a mountain side you know you know
right in front of you and with this w
mental health whether you're the most
resilient person like my dad or or
you're so driven and focused and and so
strong physically mentally or anything
like that you can fall into a hole and
if you fall into that hole uh it's known
that you know a decision can be made
that can change your life
forever and in that hole it's so cruel
that the human mind literally wants to
kill itself m
and that happened to our family um my
dad was such a strong Blok in terms of
um physically and mentally being able to
push through pain and stresses and
farming is no easy task like whether
it's Financial or animals being sick or
Banks and land and these are stresses
that he had dealt with
previously probably not efficiently
which led to um you know know falling
into into a hole but doubt with stresses
in terms of I'd never seen him um
stressed or anxious before so we get all
these stresses in dealt with them and
then when he passed like these stresses
were all what he had dealt with before
but for some reason he wasn't efficient
at dealing with them which led to his
mind falling into that hole which then
the mind as we know wants to kill itself
and and that's just so
bloody harsh and that's why individuals
need to be proactive at
recognizing things or recognizing the
mind when it dips into this hole and
that's the whole thing um for me because
I've seen like um although I haven't
been like directly like suicidal I've
seen through chronic injury and pain or
things not you know you know not going
your way and not able to see the light
at the end of the tunnel if your mind
falls into a hole you literally can't
see the light at the end of the tunnel
you you don't have hope you don't have
anything and if you're in that hole the
brain wants to kill itself and people
say oh you know you should think of your
kids and think of your um family or
anything like that but we've seen time
and time again
of super successful
wealthy um lovable people funny
people um all sorts of walks of life
whether you have addictions or no
addictions or as I said money or no
money or anything like that the mind
when it falls into a hole it can't see
out of that hole and poor decisions can
be made that you ultimately don't know
because when my dad died I said that I
just knew that wasn't my dad and I was
at home a few we you know the two weeks
leading up to his death and he just
wasn't my dad like he was not my dad and
we'd gone to the doctor um the day
before he died 10 days before he died
mom was there the whole time and she was
in it at Bing as well because stressful
times and
everything um and we were all there we
had plans in place with things um in
place and it still happened and this is
why um
fortunately my generation and
generations after us and things like
that are starting to learn and
recognize uh the actual sickness that
mental health is or whether it's anxiety
or depression and and the sickness being
that it can get you really chronically
sick that you fall into a hole and then
your brain wants to kill itself and just
being really aware of that and whether
you're as I said previously super
resilient tough old school just you have
to just really
see in reality right now what's
happening with your mind and the
proactiveness is you know the ambulance
at the the top of the hle not the bottom
of the hle the proactiveness is having a
parachute before you know jump out of
the plane you know it's it's not trying
to imagine a parachute when you're
halfway fall into the ground you know
what I mean and the parachute is um you
know understanding and being open to
efficiencies of the mind and flaws of
the human mind because humans are flawed
and nobody's perfect and if the human
and just accepting that the human mind
is is flawed allows us to see
okay um I could be in this situation
because people say oh you know I've
never had mental health issues or
anything like that I've never had mental
disruption but it's like come on man
like yeah like you might have not being
really depressed unable to get out of
bed but sure if you've challenged
yourself if you've uh tried to do better
for your family or whatever you would
face mental disruption or Challenge and
through that you would have stress or
pressure and through that you know
things come up and so just accepting
that humans are
flawed we all face mental disruption
what am I going through right now uh and
actually just cut the facade out like
just cut the facade out of of you can
handle anything you can sure like in a
healthy mind you can handle anything and
and I noticed that with my with my
career I was like okay I know that I'm
resilient and and and and tough in terms
of like being able to like work hard and
things like that I know that I can you
know push myself really hard and drive
okay and then I was noticing like I was
being so in like I wasn't good at that I
wasn't really good at handling criticism
and I was like what the heck before I
could handle lots of criticism but now
I'm just not really handing criticism
well I could push through whether it be
a Bronco or something like that like
pushed through the absolute pain barrier
whereas now I'm like I'm see feel like
I'm tapping out early or something like
that or you're on the rugy field and
like you could work really hard and then
I just noticed I was like oh what the
heck I'm just not very good at that
anymore it's not like I had all of a
sudden um not become resilient it's you
know you might have a resilience bucket
for say that's 25 L sure that's a big
bucket of resilience but if it's filled
with water and leaking over the top you
know there's no room for it it's it's
spilling it's and that's what happens
with with your mind and what happened
with me with rugby I was like I'm just
not being efficient and I'm not handling
stress and pressure as efficiently as I
can and literally accepting that and
going what can I do to be better at
handling this um literally made me go a
million times better and and through
stresses and pressures and and anxieties
and things like that if we look in rugby
and out of rugby and and life of my dad
and things like that if you look at the
situation you go okay am I actually
handling this the best way I can what's
actually going on right now how do I
better manage this right now how do I
have a better outcome even just being
open to that allows us to be open into
the chance of actually getting better M
um rather than just being like n it'll
be right toughen up carry on all these
sorts of things because as men we
naturally are like that but I challenge
it to say are we actually as efficient
as we say we
are and something just pop up in in in
mind there I heard that the Warriors did
a uh questionnaire at the end of last
year that said how resilient are you you
know lots of the individuals said yeah
I'm you know really resilient eight
nines out of tens how resilient is the
team you know fours fives and it's like
well if the individual thinks they're 8
n 10 resilient but then they say that
the team's 4 five resil on the resilient
scale you know there's something there's
something not working there so you can
be super you can think you're super
resilient but are you actually being a
efficient and effective with that
resilience and you accept okay I
probably aren't am not handling stress
or pressure or things that are going on
my mind as effectively as I can do I
have the potential to have a be super
resilient or have that full 25 lit
bucket yes um but what can I do to you
know be more efficient at it and be
better and literally just breaking that
facade down of who you think you are to
the world and being like I might not be
good enough here yeah is super scary and
for me I I was like that with my career
it was only about a year and a half ago
um because I wanted to be playing and I
I internally believed I should be
playing at this sort of level but my
results or what my actions weren't
represented of that and I again it's
almost that retirement Factor had to be
like what if I'm not going to be an all
black what if I'm not going to be the
best what if I'm not a good rugby player
at all what if I can't even play rugby
yeah and that's super scary because it's
confronting but accepting and looking at
reality right now dealing with that pain
of might not be good enough allows you
to then make a choice of action whereas
if you just continue and try to get
better and improve but not really face
reality that you might not be handling
things as best you can you just suffer
and you suffer because you get stuck in
the fantasy of being a perfect picture
you know or being this XY Z or whatever
and you're just you're just inefficient
and you're limiting yourself and I think
if we learn these things through
experiences throughout our life um from
being young to middle age to whatever
then we get better at handling them and
recognizing them and um I could probably
say that sure Dad went through stresses
and pressures and stuff but he probably
got by by gritting his teeth dealing
with it but I don't know like he might
have been
like like had anger Outburst then and so
like if someone's really angry or or
like yells at you you think you know we
all think oh well he's probably not
handling this too well you know what I
mean like if a Coach yells at you and
screams at you like but in a precious
situation like if it's to rock you up
it's rock you up but if it's in a more
precious you're like I think everyone
instinctively knows well this guy's
probably not handling it too well I mean
like things so then that's like a sure
sign that okay he's putting that hand in
it well you know what I mean and and
that's what men do do we like okay grit
our teeth toughen it out go harder work
harder pour it into work but like at the
end of the day you're not getting
efficient at doing it you're grinding
the stone down and normally you would be
able to handle stresses but some point
you might not be able to handle and the
bucket's overflowing yeah so challenge
yourself with those questions and we
have to do this because
if we don't we're always going to push
ourselves and drive right but if we
don't we can fall into a hole and we
know that if we fall into this dark hole
that we often aren't in control of the
plane and things can happen and those
things can have terrible terrible um
results and I just look at um my family
and
and as I said previously my dad was like
the most resilient good guy tough in
terms of F and all that knowledgeable
help his made out who was going through
a tough time the year before he passed
was open enough to speak to doctors but
probably wasn't proactive enough in
stopping the mind and that's probably
because he didn't know but stopping the
Mind falling into a hole and he's not
with us now so was he going to the
doctor for mental health yeah so he he
was aware he was struggling yeah and he
had support through my mom and us and
and that to to go to the doctor and ask
and this is where our our um systems
aren't great yeah they're not great
because doctors aren't trained like a
psychiatrist is trained counselors
aren't aren't even trained or or site
people aren't trained as effectively
and um
that's that's not a sign to worry but
that's a sign to to be proactive
yourself and to try to see what you can
do to be in a better situation and not
just rely on one person like speak to
this person and speak to this person and
and and get gather evidence here and see
what works for you um and that's helped
myself personally um like cuz I was uh
I've had different mental disruptions as
I said and and it was the start of last
year because I mentioned I'd driven for
a long time just to be a professional
Rob player and get in the door to play
which is often so hard to do right and
2021 I went down I didn't have anything
after Tasman season um Clark do gave me
uh two we training contract to come down
at the end of pre-season went in there
did that and then played a couple games
and so I would like because I was always
felt I was good at driving and going
hard so I'd go hard hard hard and then I
would crash and like you'd get like
injured or something like that yeah and
then go go go go go and then crash and
then go go go and crash and I was like
what the heck and then because you just
think go harder train
and yeah sure be smart in that cuz I
wasn't dumb but I was like what the heck
why am I getting injured or why would
this happen or why am I battling with
consistency um and I was like stuck in
such a sympathetic state of drive drive
drive that I was just
exhausted and I
remember um had a great offseason
preseason leading into the
2022 season for super rugby felt best of
my life and everything and then I just
felt oh yeah I need to do more I need to
do more and I went out under decis and
my back just went boom and buggered my
back and I was like all right I need to
start pre I need to start the season you
know you want to be starting the season
in the team because if you're not in the
team then it's yeah can be a tough uph
battle especially if the team starts
going well and that the coach doesn't
probably want to change it did my back
literally we play the his preseason
right felt all good um pumped up Mark L
Pablo my wanted to get into him and then
did my back that weekend because we
played Friday I think and then had like
three days and so I was like yeah I'll
get F I did my back and then um yeah
basically couldn't play next next game
but talk like um through the doctor and
that took like heaps of Tramadol and
stuff like that to try to help my back
to play um played played
poorly um to where I wanted to play and
then we were in Queenstown at that time
as well and I was just remember like
injured played
poorly um had been like wrapped up in
wanting to that end date of wanting to
be like yeah named in round one or
whatever and all of that and then I was
had I had a panic attack bro full blow
and I'd never had a panic attack what
does that look like M I just I didn't
know I was just full freak freaking out
like heart rate through the roof like
tense ass my neck was all tensed up
where were you in Queenstown yeah just
what in your room yeah just just in my
room so and and just full um you know
finish the training or whatever like
that and probably just had time to
myself just full panic attack right and
I was like what the heck and and I was I
just had to control my mind and be like
okay like you know your your mind's
trying to go off on all these tangents
and and think what ifs and Futures and
all that so I was battling with like
would I ever be a rugby player would I
ever make money would I ever let um do
what I wanted to do um and the reality
was I was in a far better position than
I was a year ago because I just signed a
new like two-year contract started
flying money like was in the
professional game I I was injury free
basically and playing well I hadn't had
didn't have a serious injury so
everything was going good but then I was
like had panicking I was like what the
heck you know and and that was a big I
opener at the
time um to actually all right I don't
know if I'm being as efficient as I
think I am and this is like I knew a bit
about m al and stuff and this is was
only 2022 like um and I was just like I
actually don't think I'm being as
efficient and um through that time
managed to um be all right and I was
still playing good rugby um things were
flowing but I had to be like well I
don't think I'm as top as I can be even
though you're playing all good um doing
all right had an all right season but I
just like wasn't internally like fully
happy
and this is where I think people can get
mistaken and they can think oh I might I
hate rugby or it's a rugby or something
like thatas I I knew it I I knew I love
rugby and I knew it wasn't rugby but
that's a sure sign that you're not doing
mentally well if you're starting to like
hate something you love Yeah
and with that I spoke to sort of like I
wanted to figure out okay I've done like
the journaling I've done the breath work
I've done the medication I've tried that
I've tried other things and they all
help and they all can help but I'm not
fully right I and I want to know why and
something that really helped me was
understanding what happens in the mind
and I se out a couple of psychiatrists
and I wanted to know like what's
happening in my mind because I felt like
I could crawl over broken glass with a
purpose in mind
but if I didn't know what was happening
I would fall victim to all these panics
or all these little things and you got
to think at the S time I'm still playing
professionally and doing all good in
that crazy yeah and I just think but I
see this all the time like I see now
like I think like literally majority of
rugby players um probably have mental
disruption or aren't at their full
capacity because they don't have proper
efficient systems to to deal with what's
going on in their mind and life and that
was me and then through that time I met
with a couple people and yeah developed
a few systems and and one of the systems
was actually um the sympathetic State I
was in such a sympathetic state which is
like uh your your high blood pressure
your eyes are like dilated you're sweaty
all the time I'm like a sweaty mess all
the time you know what I mean like
going like ready to kill it feels like
and that was that's a rugby
environment's like that all the time and
so if I'm wide like that I'm going to be
doubly like that but I was like that not
just at training but then um at night
I'd be like that and then in my recovery
I'd be like that I was doing these ice
bus and I was like that I was doing
these journaling and I'm like in this
damn ice buff like yeah yeah yeah and
it's like defeats the whole purpose of
doing it but I don't know and I do these
Journal is like yeah I'm something but
like it's it's not that's not an
effective way of using all that because
your whole time you're in this High
adrenalized basically State and then
over time you get less and less
efficient less and less efficient and
then something crashes and injuries that
was happening in a rugby I could drive
externally drive and probably when I
didn't achieve or anything that switched
internally and I was at less of
efficient less efficient and something
would happen and then it wasn't until I
used that drive that I had and then I
would at the end of the drive sessions
or something like that the sympathetic
sessions I would actively try to lower
and that's why people actively try to
lower into a parasympathetic state to
lower their arousal level to be more
efficient at the drive later on whereas
if you're just stuck in the drive that
Drive slowly goes m
and crashes but if you drive and then
reset and then drive then reset that
drive will be 100% fueled the whole time
um and that's what I started to do and
that helped shitloads yeah how have you
done that is that mainly through breath
work or well it took me a while to
understand but lots of people do the ice
bares that might do journaling or
grounding or something but it's how you
do it it's not just doing it because I
was doing that on like I'm not feeling
mentally better I'm just not I'm doing
these ice bars I'm in there 10 minutes
freezing my ass I'm not there's the
difference between like getting in there
and just holding on and just gritting
because you're in such a adrenalized
state where getting in there and
recognizing the stressor which is an ice
or something like that recognize the
stressor and allowing yourself to be
calm through it is allows basically to
control it and prolong it and
whether that's in general life or
something like that you might for
farming for example you got shitloads of
stuff to do stuff's coming at you all
the time or work things are coming at
you work's endless right there's always
work to be done and so if you're in that
moment and you're like okay I'm doing my
brief exercises it's not [__]
happening it's not working then you're
not doing it right the reason why you do
a brief exercise or something like that
is to gain control of the system so you
have a stressor something stressed you
out something's been an event and it's
recognizing that and then it's allowing
yourself through body and mind to lower
the arousal to that um
and so we look at anxiety right and we
think anxiety is it like that's the
problem but anxiety is actually a
secondary thing so there's an event that
happens and then anxiety is the
secondary thing that comes over to try
shut those feads down so we have an
event right an event will happen and we
have an internal stimulus to the event
or a feeling uh and then the anxiety
will come down to try to shut that down
we only really recognize it at the
anxiety level because it's a panic in
the mind it's a freak out it's a sweaty
Palm it's a eye dilation it's a um cold
hands or whatever whereas
second there's an event and there's a
feeling and that feeling will bring like
discomfort or whatever and then we freak
out so an example of that might be
like uh like what was something that you
would freak out in R be it might be like
conversion yeah right to win the game
right in front there you go yeah
conversion on no py
so don't listen to me probably but um if
there's a conversion to win the game
that feel
you're freaking out to win the game
because there there's a consequence to
it right yeah there's a consequence to
to doing this event there's a
consequence and there's like internal
pressure um and so that event is kicking
the goal the feeling is you might not be
good enough you might be fail your
career might be judged on that judgment
is a big one you might be done and
also uh uh system that might have been
installed while you were younger where
you went to kick and um your brother
probably you missed a kick and your
brother probably mocked the [__] out of
you lady told you he probably mock he
probably mocked you or something like
that and so you ably have a negative
experience to a similar event mate you
know too much about
me now so you're going up there to kick
right yeah you've got this event that's
provided a negative stimulus from when
you're younger or something like
that obviously there's different levels
of trauma but that could be labeled as
like a lower traum traumatic event
because it had such a stimulus to it
right so you're in there going to kick a
goal you have this um feeling of not
being good enough being judged and and
all of that sort of stuff and then the
consequences of missing you let your
team down you all the sort of stuff even
when I'm talking what are you feeling in
your body
probably like a rise in blood pressure
like tensions increasing you're starting
to feel a bit panicky in the chest um
and those stats anxiety coming yeah over
but what happens in that moment if you
recognize the event right and then you
can look at your past and be like okay
I've probably had a reaction and then
you can see you can recognize what's
happening in your body okay my body is
freaking freaking out but you got to do
what what's required and how do you do
what's required okay kick the goal I
don't know no kicker but line up the
seam follow through yeah and so you
might have developed a system that was
like head down follow through um Carry
On running through whatever and that's
the process of doing so then we look at
this process a lot and coaches say just
do the task at hand focus on the task do
the process but like where's the
education around all this sort of stuff
you know and that where I was thinking
like sure I'm doing all this stuff I'm
doing the task man but I'm not doing it
e efficiently but if you know what's
happened happens in the mind because the
mind this is like a very
predictable um pattern that happens in
all stress or all pressure situations
there's an event we have a a reaction to
that or a feeling anxiety comes through
to stop that feeling and that's like
what I said increased pressure all that
sort of stuff
but throughout all of that you have to
look at the fantasy of okay I want to
make this kick it's all evident I want
to make this kick I want to do this
because XY Z where I am in reality okay
I'm right in front of it I need to do
what do I do to get the fantasy okay
follow through head down kick whatever
and then you go and action that and
through actioning that and doing it
you'll feel better out other side
because you you know made the kick or
whatever but there's going to be a
strong reaction to that in the first
place um and just yeah recognizing that
has helped me a shitload because I
probably I know I did through habits of
as I said being injured or being dropped
or um often I would often get only like
one chance in the sort of canab or
Crusader setup because there was so many
guys there I'd only get like one chance
and then for like 6 weeks I like
wouldn't get another opportunity might
come in for a training or something and
so you come in and I do well at it um
for one event but then I wouldn't do one
for another six weeks so kind of kind of
went over my head yeah but when I was
playing week in and week out for
Highlanders like boom boom i' would be
like boom one week and then I'll be like
what the heck like I'm not as consistent
because I hadn't experienced said before
but if you you know uh recognize that
okay bang these feelings might come out
of like not being got enough being a
burden letting the team go consequences
or
whatever despite that you perform
despite that you perform despite you do
what's required know your task Know Your
Role and just get better at focusing on
that focusing on that focusing on that
and through that you action things and
then you feel better um but yeah it's a
process crazy that I'm talking talking
to a player right now I feel like I'm
talking to a mental skills coach this is
very impressive but I do want to you
mentioned like how many I can't remember
the number you said but a majority of
the players you know or you can tell are
struggling or they're not working as
efficiently so like what sort of advice
would you give to those players or what
do they need to do to become more
efficient I I'd say
immediately uh just just think okay
and situations that you go through on
the training field on the playing field
or whatever look at it and be like okay
am I actually handling this as
efficiently as I can and if you drop all
like the fantasies away and the facades
of I want to do this or I I I am because
the Perfect Image is doing this or
whatever it's like no no no no drop
those away drop things away it's it's
going to feel uncomfortable to accept
reality but look at it for me it was
like you're a [__]
yeah or just just be real harsh and be
like okay Pro the reality is I'm
probably POS at rugby self-awareness has
to come into play here right like it's
probably the most
underrated um thing in a rugby player's
career I reckon is being able to have
self-awareness of what you're good at
what you're not good at and self yeah
self-awareness isn't just recognizing
internally just yourself it's like
recognizing what other people's opinions
might be or like where you might sit in
the whole you know Echelon of everything
right because we can we as rugby players
we all like competitors or whatever like
that a lot of it's like oh fake it to
your makeup block out the noise and then
everyone this guy's like playing up you
know what I mean so there's an element
of like okay you need to look on the
reality of yourself and where you are
you might be this level of rugby but
then also what's other people saying and
it's not a point of like all their
opinions and right or anything like that
it's gathering information to see in
reality of where you are right now and
that's why I encourage people to okay
see where you are right now know where
you want to go and don't be afraid of of
cutting those loose because there's
power in the retirement as I said
because is a retirement or whatever is
coming back to reality yeah and then see
where you want to go have that North
Star and I'm probably lucky in the fact
that I'm always I'm always driven and
want to go a certain way and I think we
instinctively most people feel like in
rugby at least they know where they want
and they they want to go you know every
K kid says they want to be an all black
or whatever so know where you want to go
all of that but really get back get that
information of where you are in reality
through coaches or players and
uh an underrated quality of a good coach
is is being honest and connecting and
and that's something we're lucky and
fortunate enough through like tesman and
Highlanders and most professional rugby
to be fair in New Zealand have got to
the point where an honest coach sits you
down and be like okay look this is where
you are and this is where Andrew Goodman
was really good because he was like look
this is where like you are as a rugby
player I have full faith that you can
get here so he was showing fantasy but
he was showing the reality of where I am
he was playing on the fantasy of of
potential and then he was saying okay do
XY Z make the choice of doing XYZ and
that will put you in the best position
to get the fantasy it's not saying
you'll get the fantasy or whatever
because humans are flawed nobody's
perfect you can't predict the future but
if you see where you want to go get the
information on reality of where you are
and how you're handling things and then
go okay how do I do this XY Z and a good
way to um see that as a player after
you've done that is to be like okay um
as I just said the reality the fantasy
which is a good thing and uh the mental
side of things is
is there so what happens is there'll be
an event right and you would have you
have a freaking strong stimulus to this
event
and um and there's actually ways that
you can rewire it all right and it's
called EMDR so ey movement
desensitization and re reprocessing it's
a um it's a um psychology technique that
um yeah psychologists and and
psychiatrist and stuff use and what it
does is there'll be traumatic events
through your life and they might be
extremely significant events like um uh
in ttsd from that might be a significant
byproduct um these you know might be
natural disasters or Family Violence or
um drugs alcohol things that have
happened and or there might be minor
events and by minor I don't mean minor
is in lesser stimulus I just mean minors
and it might be um through your
childhood your brother laughing at you
or something like that you know what I
mean which is fine because when we're a
baby and we're like 0 to S as people say
you know how you would have heard oh
people you know from 0 to seven it's
it's yourself what people really saying
then is you're a bloody blob of brain
matter and you're developing systems
along the way and you're developing
software to install on that brain and
that's how you react to the world around
you right and so there's no good or bad
or good system and bad system or it's
just you are this blob of material and
you develop systems yeah through your
environment and there's a whole other
stuff you can going on about that but
just think about that and think about
okay in rugby or life am I having a
really strong stimulus to something
because something might happen I might
get dropped and I have a freaking strong
reaction to that and that reaction is
coupled with the event and what EMDR
does helps to break the event happening
and
uh reaction to it and so for me uh like
injury was a big one and cuz I injured
my net and my nerve and so if you injure
your neck and your nerve you're pretty
worried about getting a neck injury or
nerve injury in rugby again and that's
you know a big risk in rugby yeah
because um we've seen it happen and
things and so for ages I had this event
of getting injured on my neck and when I
went to play rugby again I was like
internally wored worried about tackling
and things like that we you'll have a
bit of worry but this was like worry
that I was like sick like I was like it
was a full-blown reaction like I was out
there and I was like freaking out yeah
which was um yeah which is something you
don't want and I haven't haven't done U
the EMDR on this um but this is what
happened naturally was a slow separation
of that event getting injured and and
then the reaction to that and then I was
able through that to recognize that that
injury was a oneof and it could happen
again and there's a risk that it might
happen again but you're still able to go
and
play and and through rugby like
um for example um you might have an
event of like dropping the ball or you
might be let's just say use use your
example okay kicking a goal when you
were younger you might have been laughed
at or something like that and that
provided a massive reaction and that's
coupled with the event so every time
because the brain works in predictable
ways every time you go kick a goal guess
what's going to come up that event and
that reaction to that event and they're
attached but what you can do through
EMDR it's a way of bringing up the event
and bringing up the reaction of like you
might get a dry mouth you might like
playing with your lips and getting a
tick like and like doing h of weird
stuff I don't know if you've ever
noticed people like when they're talking
to you or you might as a coach you might
be talking to players and be like they
might be playing with their tongue or
their lips or like swallowing lots and
that so that you're starting to notice
okay their anxiety you got an you got a
pretty strong reaction to this and so
identify those events identify the
strong reactions to it and EMDR can work
to to separate the two so you still have
the event but you don't have the strong
reaction to it true and then you might
be up there goal
kicking right but you don't have that
strong reaction you might still have a
little bit there but the idea is that
you don't and then you just have to
control the moment and understand what
you need to do and go and execute it
jeez I wish I I talk spoke to you 10
years earlier no it's it's not me
honestly it's not me but who no one
speaks about this well and that's what
was going to be my next question like
how how have you learned all this
because um like I'm listening to you
here I'm thinking F this guy is on to it
how's he picked that ver yeah uh I think
potentially I've always been curious
about it but I've gone gone through
certain things and if I didn't learn on
you know career done you know what I
mean yeah and and so through that
through through that um complete pain of
being in your room and just not knowing
any way out and your head is just
absolutely hurting and you just have to
look at it be there must be a way there
must be a way there's always an answer
um and I got that saying Sam there's
always a solution um to a problem
there's always an answer to a question
and there's always a meaning to a life
Sam um just keep thinking there's always
a solution there's always um you know an
answer there's always a meaning and
through that through that pain you might
be just in there just not knowing which
way to go out so if you're in the if
you're in the hole and the a way to know
that you're in the black hole is to to
see to to be there and be like [__] I'm
actually not seeing any hope or I'm not
seeing any way out so you need to get
that parachute going and the way you get
the parachute going connection is one
like might be like doctor medication
seek those professional help and so
that's a way to pull you out and for
loved ones that um that are you know
going someone might be going through
something it's to it's to provide that
connection to help them just get above
the parit a little bit and just to see
out of the hole and then through there
you can like do stuff but the main has
been there and and not been able to see
and so you got to recognize that and be
proactive and for me I guess that was
that was it like I was in the and being
in the hole through injury and career
and if I didn't uh you know you might I
wouldn't be playing rugby or something
like that and through all that you had
to be like [__] like I need to do it and
I've been fortunate enough to like um
talked to a few people talked to a few
um psychiatrists and psychologists to
just try to understand I did study
psychology at Uni is a minor so it has
always been an interest um but Sports
fascinating as well right because it's
like a test tube um it's a test tube
just to see what's going on mentally and
it's so cool to see like um it's really
exciting now where previously I'd
probably just hold on and hope as we
often do but now it's like okay this is
exciting I want to be in the test Tu I
want to be in the biggest Arenas
whatever and just see what goes on in my
mind what goes on in the 15 people
around you the opposition how do you
reacting to situations and then being
able to execute like you look at Nathan
clear in that grand final he missed um
two crucial tackles um before that or
whatever how many players do you see who
make a mistake or they don't start the
game or I said I've seen players like
you talk to players right you probably
spoken to players and they'd be like
yeah I just I need to have a good hit or
a good carry and I'll have a good game
and if I don't first need to get in the
game early Jesus I'm like if I'm playing
against him I'm like yeah I got this guy
I got this guy good because
like like rugby is such an unpredictable
sport at times like if you don't do car
your whole game is derailed like you're
setting yourself up for failure and we
set ourselves up for failure because
we're in a sport that need you need to
be perfect you need to do things well
there's consequences there's um all
these sorts of things but um yeah like
Nathan clear going back to that point
couple Miss tackles uh three tries up
for isra and M Broncos on absolutely hum
what are you do in that situation you
know the Mind wants to escape because
back when we were young you know early
doors that fight or flight stimulus was
there to protect us right and so the
Mind wants to get out of that situation
but as I said Sports a great test tube
you're in that moment you want to flight
you want to freak out you want to get
tense or whatever like that what does he
do he steps up makes a 4020 um makes a
few passes to line steps in scores a try
people are under fatigue and that's the
beautiful Arena to do that like this
like and mentally I think for sport like
so many people are are are there
physically and everything like that but
mentally is like
and that's something I've been really
excited about and and so excited that
been able to like Implement a little bit
I want to do way more but you just see
it on the field day and like it's such a
beauty beautiful Arena to try to do that
and that's why rugby is such a good
sport because there's um 15 people on
each side there's all different shapes
and sizes there's different skills and
abilities um some like so many different
people's things that happen in their
lives and everything like that
everything goes in to affecting what
happens on the field and as a coach or
whatever like that [__] that must be so
stressful because you just like okay
I've taught all these guys everything
I've prepared them as well as I can and
then on the weekend they don't do it I
must be like Jesus I'm a player and I'm
already Bor imagine me as a coach I like
terrible but as a player um you're in
there doing it and you can test yourself
and the BLS around you or a woman around
you to do it and isn't that exciting so
cool and mate this got me excited for
watching you play for tasmine this
weekend just putting the boys on your
back like
Clary oh I wish I was already one I had
that bank account two I had that looks
and then three had those skill set but
he's already he's two years younger than
me too the as long as you've got the
mindset that's all that matters and
that's all I've learned from this but I
do have one more question question sort
of for you that I was thinking about
after talking to Sam matavesi on the
podcast a few weeks ago um he spoke
about um losing his mom at a young age
and how hard it was for him to sort of
get over so obviously you lost your dad
and I guess it's around advice for
people who do lose someone close to them
because obviously suicide rates at a
ridiculous ridiculously high rate at the
moment
um people are losing loved ones he spoke
about how there's not enough support for
people who do lose people close to them
and how hard it is to deal with so I was
just thinking if there's anything there
from you yeah I think um like for
example what you're doing is providing
people platform and asking those
questions because there's things um as
we've just spoken about that didn't help
me and then that have helped me and
there's so many people out there who
have gone through things before and you
don't have to go through these things
and that's the thing like um people also
say oh you know you learn all this stuff
no I was going to learn all the stuff
anyway or like you know things this
might happen in this but no
um you can learn by um yeah things that
have happened and actually there's uh
there's systems and just learn a system
and so by you asking these questions um
yeah thanks very much um for that
because it does help people I believe
look um what happened to my family is
was super like just so so tragic and
we've got a lot of work to do in New
Zealand with men with women uh with
generally knowledge and understanding
and I
think your life changes
forever my life and my family's lives um
changed forever and and we carry that
hurt like every day all day and we'll
never get over that hurt you never do
you take the qualities of uh the people
you love and you try to emulate that
every day and I try to be uh the man
what my dad was uh he was a great man to
our family and um worked hard and and
had really great qualities and so you
try to do that and I think that's a way
that you honor them um but you also
acknowledg like it's
[__] like I
um I'm going to have to car for the rest
of my life and and I remember the last
time I saw my dad
alive and I was sitting I was standing
across the fence on the farm
and just he was holding my side like
just holding
and and hugged him goodbye I didn't
think he was going to
die and we always trusted that trusted
him and trusted that the plans we' put
in place and and so for that you you
can't trust someone in that space and
you need to be proactive if you are in
that
space um but we're going to
live with that forever and and people
live with things forever um but if you
take the
qualities you take the qualities that
they live
by and you you put that in you and you
uh try live their legacy and um help
people I think I get a real
um first by that probably helps me by by
sharing these stories like I because I
just I don't want anyone to have to go
through
that like and and that's that's the
heartache of suicide and tragic death or
anything like you yeah we carry that all
the time that's not to mean that you
can't live your life and do these things
um the humans are we bloody resilient
but it these things don't have to happen
as well and they don't have to happen
for you to learn and live for the wife
that you want it's just a hole that's
there forever and so the advice that I'd
give to anyone who's lost anyone young
is is try to um live the good values
that they had um connect and and and be
tight with your loved ones I think
that's a beautiful thing um that my mom
and two sisters are really strong
beautiful woman and and we have a great
bond together uh we did before and we do
now um so continue to to have that and
relationships with people are the
ultimate i' I feel probably having
relationships with um friends and family
and you helping people and people help
you and trying to have those connections
because uh that's where yeah that's
that's probably what we remember at the
end of the day and anyone's going to be
driven to do any amounts of things in
terms of what they want to achieve in
their life and that's fine um some
people will just be happy and content
with a certain level and some people
want to drive but throughout all of that
is relationships and connection so to
grow that and yeah through that I think
well that's what I I've taken from my
dad it's death but you never get over it
you're always left of a hole and and
sometimes like um I would seem fine and
then other times just really miss them
like um like the sixth anniversary of
Dad's passing was only a month ago um
his birthday yeah was a few days ago and
in those times are always really tough
the firsts are tough the first are so
tough yeah because it's so unknown and
um and those will always be emotions but
it's right to feel those emotions I
think don't block them off because we
don't want to block them off um we just
want to we want to see for what it is
and work through it and be okay and
that's for anyone um not just who's lost
the loved one but anyone that's going
through
something is
is I know it's scary and
unknowing um but don't be afraid to just
stand there and be like okay you know
where am I right now what do I want to
do what are ways for me to action and
move forward because for a long time
there like um I was happy with rugby and
things like that but I just wasn't happy
and I was like I'm I want to be happy I
want to be
happy uh and then I was engulfed in a
lot of times wanting to be happy but
then not doing anything about it but
through
actioning things um you wake up one day
and you're like oh I'm actually happy
because I'm actioning things yeah so I
it's like the weather it's you know
sometimes it's sunny sometimes it's
rainy sometimes you're happy sad or
whatever but you just continually move
forward through actioning where your
reality to your fantasy is bridge that
Gap and and you know you'll be happy and
it's like I think that's something
that's really helped me this year um and
for this year like I've probably had
like four or five days when I haven't
been happy um whereas the year before
was probably four or five days that I
was happy yeah all the other days I
wasn't so everyone goes through
everything um and you just yeah just
connect really because through that
connection um like what we're doing
where uh we're talking that's why I'm
big believer in therapy and things like
that because therapy is not just about
them telling you what to do it's about
you things and then figuring things out
in yourself yeah having that
introspection and self awareness think
think things through figure them out for
yourself um ask questions of yourself um
but keep that Sam alive keep that
Solutions answers and meaning um I think
that's a big one and that's probably
yeah M that is such powerful stuff and
um it's so so cool to hear you speak so
honestly and openly and knowledgeably
about the whole um situations that
you've been through and the ones that
you're in and um yeah so cool to be able
to share it on this platform but um mate
you've made I think you've made me a
better Coach better better person and
unfortunately a better player listening
to that too late for me now but um I'm
sure so many people would have got a lot
out of that I think there's so much good
in there and um like I said looking
forward to watching your career
knowing what you know now and seeing you
implemented on the field in that test
tube like you like to call it um it's
going to be cool to watch you and um
follow the journey a little bit closely
no cheers cheers for having me and and
like I've said before it's cool that um
a person of your talent is able to share
a platform um and help people and that's
at the end of the day like telling
stories and and people connecting
through that and helping through that
like [__] we're in n and Club rooms
right now
like allowed to do that but like this is
what Rugby's about man this is what the
core fabric of New Zealand is about and
this is what we just need to keep
reminding um and living because
connections and talking and helping and
um working together uh those are all the
all the awesome qualities of of that we
have in rugby yeah that we've that we
learn and
and we don't want to lose that uh in
rugby and post rugby as you say because
um post rugby prevents another presents
another um Challenge and but keep them
going so yeah thanks for um doing that
and yeah bringing me on I probably
mumbled a lot and and didn't make sense
but hopefully a little bit of it made
sense learning sense all made sense and
you are an absolute lad 52 so appreciate
you coming on mate it's been awesome
cheers jimy geez what an episode that
was awesome to have Hugh come on and
share some tips and tools from his
journey what an incredible journey he
had and if you got something out of that
episode let me know let me know in the
comments I will get back to everyone who
does write something in there so it' be
cool to hear um what you got out of that
episode and if you're not already
subscribed to the water Leed YouTube
channel do so now please it does um help
massively and um appreciate all the
support hope you enjoyed it